en
lui l'a vous le reconnaissez sans doute
c'est valentin des le designer que tout
paris s'arrache quelles sont vos
influences au je dirais principalement
nous mêmes
et voilà comment dire cnc sa famille
rapide à quelques 6 milliard est riche
il ya de grandes idées bros
j'allais donc comme je sais pas tes
oignons d'aller vers l'autre produit
qu'à paris pain d'ailleurs il n'était
pas du tout prévu qu'ils se revoient
demi à la maman heureusement la vie est
bien faite aux jeunes filles tu m'as
tellement mal que je sais pas me chez
l'autre bonjour madame
il a deux mois pour faire le plus de
progrès possible
passé ce délai il restera comme ça
arrive qu'est ce que c'est allez hop nom
offre
comme bien des gens fous de la kul
seulement qu'il veut
[Musique]
veuillez anthony ici oui moi vous êtes
bien d'une heure n'est ce pas où que
j'aille oxmo je vois je vais il va bon
train les grisons ont pas besoin
là il pleut des cordes pas de douche
chaude rocheleau sais c'est moche
stadiou stade rochelais jean point vous
êtes là comme ça mais il met forcément
dans le nord